you got your favorite movies oh good
fellas has got to be one of them yeah
man on fire is oh
uh
godfather two
john q have you talked to all these guys
huh sammy the bull sami i was pretty
fascinated with him he's the only
gangster that i
was really taken with because he i knew
who he was back in the day because i was
in new york then and he was terrifying
you know but
he just seems like a very intelligent
guy who had if it wasn't for his
dyslexia would probably be a huge
entrepreneur it would probably be a guy
who made a fortune like i i know it's
crazy to say this but i get the feeling
that even though he was a killer he
lived by that code of the samurai he's
i i look at him as more of a samurai you
know people who kill people are
you know gangsters are bad people right
they just i don't like it there's
something about that guy i feel like he
was just more of a modern-day
moto musashi like like a like a samurai
who lived by the sword and was always
ready to die by the sword that that's my
feeling i may be wrong i don't know what
was your impression i mean sammy is uh
till today he is still to the core proud
mafioso he'll tell you when we
spend those three days in the mountains
and we did the mafia states of america
with him and uh michael franzis you
spent three days with him oh yeah we we
had we in the mountains in the mountains
with with and that was what we did with
uh rudy giuliani and we had chance palm
and terry do the do the narration wow
how is it so fast security wise what's
this oh we have to have security
bananas nice they both asked to bring
their own people and is that true
they're each the people that they
brought on each side you know it's like
they're they're people people they
brought their own people so you do you
have to because i'm asking them to come
to the top of a mountain at a house that
matches identical to the house from
godfather too helicopter comes down
it was a great uh are you nervous about
that that was
no because i've already done a lot of
stuff with both of them i had first time
i talked i called sammy it was uh a year
and a half after the michael frenzie's
interview so i call sammy he gets out of
jail i one of my uh the girls jessica
gets his number and i call him i say hey
sammy this is patrick with david who the
[ __ ] is this sir patrick david i
conducted the interview with michael
francis so you the mother so you did the
interview you realized michael wasn't a
boss he was a couple and i'm an
underball and he got all technical
so he went two hours furious about the
interview and i said sami just meet with
me he says no
i said sammy let's just have a meeting
i'd like to interview he says no the
only person that's ever interviewed me
is diane sawyer 1994 got 20 million
views i'm not doing any more interviews
wow so i said why don't i just come fly
it says no hangs up
i said okay i'm gonna follow up because
i'm a sales guy so i'm gonna follow up i
love it i followed up
here followed up
and finally who's this sammy it's
patrick why are you calling again and
then anyway so we talked finally
you know he agreed to meet in in phoenix
so i fly into phoenix and he says i'll
give you an address last minute when you
guys get here so we get an address we go
to this place
and a guy comes to the front he says
here let me take you to the back we're
walking walking walking walking walking
place gets dark or walking
it's me and mario mario says pat is
today the last day i'm living i said
nobody just relax you're never gonna
leave this place so we get to the place
we sit down
and then sammy shows up and he starts
talking
and he shakes your hands oh yeah yeah he
starts asking questions but the entire
time he's just watching
your body language what you're doing
what you're saying asking questions
asking mario questions why do you want
to do this what's the outcome of this
how am i going to know this this is not
going to be a hit job what's it going to
do is this anyways very very very short
you know he's done so many sit downs in
his life smart guy the kind of sit downs
that your life depends on it right
anyways six months after that he agreed
we did the interview
and uh it did very well and then this
the scariest person though that we met
with wasn't sammy it's two other guys
frank colada was one and sunny francie's
sonny francis was michael's dad he was
like if you ask sammy about sonny
francie's he's the level of respect
because if you sonny's the one that was
the rumor had it that he used to be with
jackie kennedy and marilyn all the
stories that people say about jackie and
marilyn monroe it was a sunny story
that's who sonny was i mean it was a
massive article done us simon
sonny that 50-something years in jail
so we go to new york to meet sunny at
the old folks homes after he got out of
jail okay we go to the hospital to see
him
and i go in there with mario
sunday looks at me like this he's
looking like 10 second pause he's still
looking at me not moving just like this
imagine somebody looks at you like this
and then he looks at mario like this for
10 seconds
he says you rat
to mario you rather know he says you
know 95 percent of the world they're
rats you rat
and mario's like
doesn't know what to say he's looking at
me
he's looking at me like i'm like
sonny he's totally fine he's a good guy
he's been with me for 15 years so you're
not a rat no
okay good well good good having you here
let's go and then we sat down and i was
trying to do the interview with him
toughest sail look how he is
uh by the way he died a year ago a year
and a half ago and that's michael and
his dad where is he right in the middle
there uh but in the picture he's the one
in the middle right there yeah look at
that face right there okay some of the
stories about him it's a myth i can't
even tell the story some of the stories
they say about what he did anyway so we
go back part two i got my whole camera
crew there everybody's there we're about
to do the interview
i'm taking him to the top italian
restaurant to see if he's gonna be
comfortable we're driving to the
restaurant
and i said so sonny you know
what do you think about marilanski
because he comes from that era
good man a very good man i said really
was he a billionaire no just a regular
man but he was a good man
so what do you think about uh
lucky
oh
phenomenal man very good man
i said to stories about what lucky did
never very good man yeah that's it i
said how about something
that's what you'll get i said how about
bugsy you'd never call him bugsy to his
face
to you his ben siegel very good man fine
gentlemen yeah so i go how about frankly
you know so i'm going through all these
stories
i said sunny
let's do the interview because if you
don't do the interview the world's going
to tell your story how about you do the
interview with me
and let you in control the narrative you
tell the story let the audience make the
decision
and he's looking at me like thinking
about it and his lawyer sitting to his
left
it was the most uncomfortable lunch
because a lawyer screaming shouting you
know it's very ugly at this point it's
like 15 people at this table we've shut
down the italian restaurant it's just us
michael's sitting to my left his lawyers
there our people are here everyone's
waiting for sunny to say yes
and then all of a sudden he's like
yeah listen
here's all i have
all i have that i'm taking to my death
but with me
is i've never
ratted anybody out and i'm not going to
talk
to anybody
that's why he did 55 years yeah he could
only did you understand do you ever see
a movie called angels with dirty faces
with james cagney
it's a great movie because it's about
it's about one guy who gets caught
there they're two juvenile delinquents
one guy gets caught the other guy gets
away from the cops the guy who gets away
from the cops becomes a priest the guy
who gets caught gets stuck in the system
becomes a gangster that was the guy from
made at ma top of the world right so he
becomes a gangster and the greatest
thing about that movie is this
they finally catch him
he's going he's going to the chair he's
going to get electrocuted and the priest
his old friend who couldn't who ran
faster his old friend came to comes to
james and me and james cagney's in the
jail cell and he's like i'll die like a
man i'm not afraid of these these people
you know i'm i die like i die like i
live i'm a man and and uh the priest
comes to him and says i want you to do
me a favor and he says what and he says
i want you to go to the chair like a
coward
and james cannon goes what and he goes i
don't want you to go to the chair like a
brave man because these kids on the
street will look up to you and i don't
want them to look up to you wow i want
you to go to the chair like a coward and
he goes all i got all i got is this
that's all i got and you want to take
that away from me in the last moment of
my life you want me to be a go to the
chair yellow which was a coward like a
coward and he goes i do
and he goes i'm not doing it get out of
here
that's all i got and the priest leaves
with his head hung low
and then you see
james cagney being walked to the chair
and it's done the shadows on a wall
gangster please walk out i got this i
got it i got this and he's walking like
a man and like damn he didn't do it and
then just when he's gonna go he goes i
can't do it no no
i don't want to die and they have to
drag him to the chair and then you see
the kids reading and it says you know
what's his name goes to the chair like a
coward and the priest is just watching
these kids going man i always looked up
to him and he went there like a coward i
don't know is this really worth it man
that's the how you how it ends
it's called angels
and he goes come on boys let's go have a
drink for the for a kid who couldn't run
as fast it's a great movie man but james
cagney had his best there i mean how
about that what a freaking story how
about that dude i mean that that's
that's the but that's what the opposite
of what sunny did
sunny went and sunny went and said no
this is who i am yeah to the core by the
way you know the number with sunny is
55. you know sammy's got 19. sunday's
number was 55. bodies kills people oh my
goodness that's the number that you're
52 or 55 they can it's somewhere around
the 50s
102 103 and a half years when he died
that's why you can ask him about lucky
and meyer and those guys because a
hundred and four years ago it was 1918.
imagine that so you know also i think
there might be something to the fact
that
you know people are born gangsters
sometimes people like sunny uh like uh
sammy the bull they're born what would
we do without our bad guys
movies and life would be pretty boring
what would cops do without our bad guys
did you ever hear the story about their
core that way that story that sonny told
us sitting at the table on the podcast
about the guys
i'm sorry yeah that that samuel told us
yeah was that not the most intense story
one of the most intense stories what do
you mean the story about the the guy who
was a hitman's hitman yeah
that was the most intense story i've
ever seen in my life bro dude that's
where you just go and but
sammy the boat gurana might be the best
storyteller i've ever seen and i'm in
the business of telling stories yes you
want to talk about a storyteller and the
thing about it is i believe every single
word that guy says that's the other
thing that i really appreciate i'm
pretty good at reading [ __ ] that's
my you know i'm an actor would you want
to interview him yeah would you want to
have him on the podcast i would i'll be
okay i would love all right
really are you you're one i'm really
okay i'll make the mic the introduction
really
how do you get not to cut you off by my
bad how do you get sammy the bulls
number how does that happen
he's passionate hey do you better not
read
let me tell you let me tell you a real
funny story and then we'll wrap up this
has been a blast but so we go to a local
restaurant here who's uh called casa
d'angelo if you haven't been we got to
take you okay you're gonna lie i told
joe i said joe they got the best veal
not veal best elk you got to go to this
place to try to elk he says when i'm out
there we'll figure it out but uh so i'm
out to florida we moved to fort
lauderdale from boca we moved to fort
lauderdale
and first week i'm going to casa de
angelo this is known as people would go
to this place to eat the owner's name is
angela it's purely all italian employees
80 italian all of them like from italy
so first time i go eat there i go there
with uh chess momentary
so the manager comes out the owner comes
out oh okay who's this guy we go to the
corner we sit there okay
second time i go there a week after that
yeah it's with michael francis look oh
michael francis hey you know him so can
we go there third time i go there is
with sammy this is three weeks in a row
i'm going there so it's chas you
remember this right because we forget
about all three of those they're all
three so we go chaz we go michael we go
by the way chaz is dinner what's one the
best dinners of all time
i love that guy so the third one we go
is with sammy
by the fourth one it was the week that i
was on rogan i was on his podcast so on
the podcast i give a shout out to the
restaurant casa d'angelo
by the fifth time we went back there
these guys are thinking about i'm
italian and they're thinking i'm like
you know
from italy
i said you're you're a syrian that's an
original italian what do you think where
do you think the romans get it yeah from
armenia and assyria yeah
i tell you what though man the the the
story obviously you're you're you know
fascinated by the story
and it never gets old because there's
more stories yeah you know when sammy's
telling the stories or michael's telling
the story frank colada when we
interviewed him i'm in vegas
and we're staying at the mgm mario is
setting up the place if you can pull up
frank colorado so he knows who frank
colada is
so do you remember seeing so we walk in
frank walks in and mari says oh frank we
ready we have everybody ready here to to
do the interview you know i'll i'll text
it to you so you know who it is frank's
like yeah don't worry i've been sitting
out there for 30 minutes who was the guy
that came and dropped off the camera and
the lights and all that stuff tell me
who that guy is because that's what i've
been watching whoa holy [ __ ] so mario's
like oh oh uh that that's that's one of
us you sure he's one of you that's him
frank colada okay trust anybody bro oh
let me tell you so
he walks in if you've never seen the
interview
he walks in zero like hey
zero hitch cold as ice
when the interview ends
i'm talking to mario on this side to
check to see if we're gonna grab one of
the lights or to leave
we will we look around he disappeared
gone gone he disappeared no no hi buy
nothing he's gone he disappeared he
messaged me a year after that he says
hey i had no idea our sit down was going
to get these many millions of views he
says my business is taking off in vegas
let's do something
a couple weeks later he dies he just
died now if you don't know this
business himself if you don't know who
you are don't ask jewelry
he came from chicago apologizing he's in
the garbage can what's wrong with you by
the way frank colada frank colada if you
want to know who he is
you ever seen a movie uh uh casino yeah
of course you know who tony spelatra is
okay tony spelatra is like the sammy of
vegas let's just say like that guy like
a phil leonetti of vegas
in the movie if you've seen casino
remember when they go to the scene where
they put the head in the vice and they
the guy that blows up the guy in the
head and device that's
colada move he did that oh wow that's
crazy that's frank collapsed very bad
guy very bad qualifiers guys are a real
associate yeah that's like they don't
care about he is cold like you yeah cool
way brian the way that you tell stories
the accents the things that you you're
gonna have a great time with sammy if
you can set that up yeah the guy can
tell stories and if he didn't oh i know
end up in that life he could have been
entertained with comedian it's that i've
said that
you're an elite okay yeah we'll set that
up i've seen it man i appreciate it yeah
we'll set that thanks for having me if
you do if you do have a month you know
set it up for a couple hours you know
you know set it up for a couple hours
he makes his own time i'm not going
anywhere
yeah you'll have him on
the fighter in the kid oh i'd love it
yeah how often do you do that twice a
week twice and it's just you and brenda
me just me and brennan okay guys so that
would be sick so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you